hey 42 here what do arnold vossly
saint teresa of calcutta the boy king
tutankhamun
the woman who forcibly ejected you from
her body on the day you were born
and otsi the iceman have in common
they're all mummies although for the
purpose of this video
we're only really interested in the ones
whose soft tissues were preserved
long after their deaths thanks to the
process of mummification
not that i've got anything against your
mum it's a weird name
isn't it mummy and interestingly enough
the term actually comes from a bit of
misunderstanding
you see when europeans first saw the
mummified bodies of ancient egypt's dead
they mistakenly identified the strange
black substance that often coated them
as bitumen the stuff we now use to
surface our roads
the persian word for bitumen is mummier
and it's from here we ended up with the
modern term
mummy despite the fact many egyptian
mummies
weren't actually preserved in bitumen at
all
this little mix-up was also the reason
the ingestion of ground-up mummies
became a roaring health fad in europe
beginning in the 12th century
because bitumen was well known for its
medicinal purposes
check out my video on corpse medicine
for this and other weird and wonderful
reasons people chose to eat dead bodies
throughout history now i'm willing to
bet that whenever you hear the word
mummy
at least in this context you immediately
think of egypt
and that's perfectly natural we've been
fed a steady diet of undead egyptians in
popular culture
ever since the mummy first hit cinemas
in 1932
but in reality mummification has been
practiced
all over the world and mummified remains
have been discovered
on every single continent without
exception
although admittedly the ones in
antarctica were penguins
i should point out that antarctica's
mummies weren't preserved by some
last and ancient race who just so
happens to really love
penguins but by the original mummy
herself
mummy nature deliberately mummified
remains have been found on all other six
continents though
and mummification has been practiced by
many different cultures
besides just the egyptians including the
aztecs the incas the maori
one or two chinese dynasties and many
many more
we tend to think of mummification as an
ancient practice
again we probably have the egyptians to
thank for that but that
isn't entirely true either whilst
full-on mummification
is uncommon these days one of the key
stages of mummification
embalming which is the preservation of
human remains to forced all
decomposition
is still widespread in countries like
the us that favor open casket funerals
and even full-on mummification might not
be quite so ancient as you'd think
in fact in one part of europe it was
still being carried out
right up until the start of the 20th
century
home to mount hetzner birthplace of
archimedes
and infamous for its connection to the
mafia
sicily is an autonomous region of italy
and the largest island in the
mediterranean it's also
the unlikely home of what might just be
the largest single collection of mummies
anywhere in the world not that you'll
find them displayed behind sheets of
glass and some renowned museum
every single one of them is tucked away
underground
in the eerie casacolms located beneath
the capuchin monastery
in the city of palmyra the sicilian
capital
the mummies of sicily have little in
common with the ancient
and more famous egyptian counterparts
they aren't the bodies of venerated
pharaohs kings or emperors
and unlike tooting car moon and co
sicilian mummies
aren't buried in solid gold sarcophagi
alongside jewels precious artifacts
and pots of honey well past its cell by
date in fact
many were regular people like you
and me the story of how so many of them
came to be mummified on the island of
sicily
begins in 1534 with the building of a
monastery
by a group of capuchins that's
capuchin's as in
friars of a little-known catholic order
not
ross's monkey from friends to begin with
the catacombs were little more than a
single large chamber
built into the natural cave system that
lay beneath the monastery
and it was here the frayers of the
capuchin order were laid to rest upon
their deaths
it was fairly crude as far as burials go
more of a mass grave than anything else
and by the end of the 16th century
after 70 odd years of admissions
it was beginning to get a little crowded
down there to free up space for
future burials the friars began further
excavating the cave system
extending the catacombs to create a new
larger space for the dead it was decided
that the previously deceased friars
should also be relocated to the new area
presumably so they didn't feel left out
of all the excitement
but when it came time to exhume their
bodies
the still living friars discovered
something
remarkable many of their long dead
brothers
were not as had been expected
many piles of bones and dust
45 of them had become perfectly
preserved mummies their bodies
so little changed by death and decades
underground
they were still easily recognizable as
the men they'd been in life
naturally this apparent miracle came as
quite a shock to the friars
and considering the terrifying plays
mummies hold in popular culture today
you might think the capuchins would have
buried their creepy new cadaver
collection
in the deepest cave possible before
burning the monastery to the ground
and setting sail for anywhere else
but being thoroughly religious types as
frayers are
and without the influence of hollywood's
future smear campaign against mummies
the friars quickly came to a very
different conclusion
that this strange turn of events was
probably a sign from the big man
upstairs
an endorsement of the piousness of their
fallen brethren
and hey for all i know this might really
have been
a straightforward case of divine
mummification
then again it's probably a bit more
likely to be
the excellent ventilation in the
catacombs combined with the extremely
dry atmosphere
created by the absorbent properties of
the surrounding tough
which had something to do with it but i
guess you never know
tough is essentially volcanic ash that's
turned to stone over time
through a process known as lithification
but our capuchin friars weren't up to
much when it came to geology
so they stuck to the divine intervention
hypothesis
the only question was what were they
going to do with all the mummies
any ideas well if you guessed arrange
them in a variety of different poses all
over the catacombs
like creepy as hell statues made out of
genuine humans
then i'm impressed you got it in one
now as i'm sure you're aware spontaneous
acts of mummification
are notoriously difficult to keep quiet
and soon enough word got around that
burial in the capuchin catacombs
was a surefire way not only to get into
god's good books
but to quite literally save your own
skin in the process
and so before long a trickle of requests
started to come in
for the chance to be preserved in the
catacombs
at first this honor was only granted to
wealthy patrons and benefactors of the
church
in return for generous donations but
eventually
admission was opened up to the general
public meaning
anyone and everyone could opt to be
mummified upon their untimely demise
and thousands of people did exactly that
most underwent the same natural
mummification process as the original 45
friars only with a little more
preparation up front
that included the removal of the
internal organs which were replaced with
bay leaves and straw
to aid with drying and stave off the
smell and the year spent sealed up in a
room known as the collateo
here the corpses will be placed on
terracotta channels to allow the various
disgusting fluids we're all full of to
slowly drain away
as the body desiccated in times of
epidemic the mummies in waiting were
also dusted down with
arsenic as a disinfectant which sounds
pretty dangerous
but not even the strongest poison can
kill a corpse
becoming totally impervious to all known
poisons
is one of the more underrated benefits
of dye ink if you ask me
on top of this simple preparation the
richest amongst those buried in the
catacombs
could opt for the premium mummification
package
my marketing terminology not theirs
which included the injection of various
chemicals into the body
to aid in preservation though this
service was only granted
to a very small percentage of the
catacombs residents
once fully mummified the bodies would be
dressed in their sunday best
and space would be found for them in a
niche along the catacomb walls
where they would remain so long as the
family continued paying their fees
the mummies would be visited in much the
same way we visit graves today
but instead of flowers and candles
relatives will bring
new outfits for their dearly departed to
wear which does sound a bit creepy
granted but then again i wouldn't want
to be seen dead in the same outfit for
several hundred years either
and yes i am aware of the irony of that
joke coming from a man who's worn braces
and a shirt in every youtube video for
over a year
the capuchin catacombs accepted sicily's
dead
for some 300 years during which time
it's thought more than 8 000 people were
buried there
1 200 of whom were given the full mummy
treatment
most of them still stand in their silent
vigil
beneath the earth to this day their
bodies were separated according to seven
different categories
men women virgins children
priests monks and professionals
the world's changed quite a bit in the
last few hundred years hasn't it
imagine if your local supermarket
started offering virgin only parking
not that anyone would actually use it
there's only so much humiliation
a shorter walk to the car could ever be
worth
most of those buried in the catacombs
were important people in their day
but perhaps the most famous residence
now
wasn't known at all in her own time the
catacombs were officially closed to new
burials as far back as 1880
but a few exceptions were made in the
decades that followed
one such exception was made for the
mummification of a girl
of just two years of age rosalia
lombardo who died from pneumonia caused
by the spanish flu
a devastating epidemic that may have
killed as many as 100 million people
around the world
in the space of just two years at the
tail end of the first world war
unlike most of the residents of the
capuchin catacombs
rosalia lombardo's body was artificially
preserved
with a cocktail of chemicals at the
request of her grief-stricken father
and the results were remarkable
because today just over 100 years later
little rosalia lombardo is perhaps
the best preserved mummy anywhere
in the world she's affectionately known
as the sleeping beauty by the locals
and it isn't hard to see why the
perfection
of rosalie's preservation is exceptional
but for over 80 years nobody knew
how it had been achieved that changed in
when a handwritten note by alfredo
salafia
the acclaimed embalmer who had preserved
the body
was discovered by the curator of the
catacombs salafia had himself
been dead almost 75 years when the note
was discovered
but in it he'd recorded the exact
formula
used in the embalming process which
included
formalin zinc salts alcohol salicylic
acid
and glycerin as well as her pristine
condition
rosalia lombardo is famous for another
reason
rumor has it she blinks several times a
day
revealing perfectly preserved blue eyes
there are many theories as to why this
happens
some say her eyelids move a fraction of
an inch
depending on the temperature in the
crypt and others predictably
assign some paranormal significance to
the phenomenon but the curator of the
catacombs believes the whole thing is
simply an optical illusion
caused by the changing angles of
sunlight throughout the day
it's no longer possible to be buried in
the capuchin catacombs
but plenty of fresh bodies arrive there
every day all the same
admittedly they are all still breathing
hopefully
and most prefer to be called tourists
rather than bodies
but that's just political correctness
gone mad if you ask me
it's a bit of a strange place to visit
purely for recreational purposes
but it is certainly unique and it offers
an
unprecedented insight into sicilian life
and more importantly death throughout
the centuries
so much so that scientists are taking
interest in what is
a valuable cultural and scientific
window
into the past thanks to their mostly
natural preservation
the bodies still exist in varied states
of decay
some are little more than skeletons
whilst others appear remarkably lifelike
complete with leathery skin and tufts of
hair
but overall the mummies are a hardy
bunch
having survived not only the ravages of
time
but also mold bacterial infestation
fire flood damage and bombardment during
world war
ii and creepy as they may be
let's hope they stick around a little
while longer yet
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you